hi i'm faye calop and this is my cover
of the hills for stand out TV
[Music]
your men on the booty doom promo you'll
see keep up business on the low-low I'm
just trying to get you out the friend
zone
cuz you look even better than the photos
I can't find your house send me the info
you have into the gated residential
found out ABS come and send your friends
home keep on tryna had it bought your
friends know I only kill you and it's
half past five the only time that I'll
be by your side I only love it when you
touch me not feel me when I messed up
the through me I messed up through me
yeah I only kill you and tough past five
the only time I'll ever come you man I
only love when you touch me not feel me
when I messed up through me I messed up
through me it I'm gonna let you know and
keep it simple trying to keep it up
don't seem so simple I just fought two
[ __ ] fast are you you gonna have to
do it at my tempo always trying to sue
me after rehab truck started to feeling
like it's DK I'm just trying to leave
that for the moment all these
[ __ ] watery pipes I only kill
you when test fab the only time that
I'll be by sad I only love it when you
touch me not feel me when I messed up
through me
I messed up through me I only got winter
dust Bobby only time I left you I only
love rain touch me not feel me when I
messed up through mute I messed up
through me the hills have eyes
the hills have eyes who you to judge
who you to judge height or dies by
heightened eyes only you to trust only
you to trust
I only tell you where to type just by
beyond the time now if I so sad I only
love it when you touch me not feel me
when I messed up sue me when I messed up
through me yeah I only call you when top
five the only time I left you man I only
love it when you touch me not feel me
when I messed up the cerebrum you and I
messed up through me
they said he changes when the Sun Goes
Down they said he changes when the Sun
Goes Down they said he changes when the
sun goes down around here
[Music]
they said it changes when the Sun Goes
Down oh the river one now of town
they said it changes when the Sun Goes
Down round here
[Music]
you